girl tie your hair up if you wanna be a
star Billy eilish from Jimmy Kimmel and
she said that she kind of discovered you
through gatekeeper I heard this on
gatekeeper that she has 30 million
people want a shot and it blew my mind
reach out to her I I just actually
posted the song on my actual account and
I was like this is the most incredible
thing I've ever heard in my life she
said you're one of the best writers
she's like one of the most talented
she's probably like the best writer I've
ever met besides my brother got to write
with her and this friendship having her
as a confidant must be so special she's
great I love seeing her win I love
seeing her whole family succeed and went
to the tour was great
[Music]
has Billy heard yesi yeah well by
default yeah because we did a bunch of
it when we were on the tour together too
and what does she think she said it was
awful
scratch oh man she always shows love oh
now you're working also another project
with Sam Smith I am the song Perfect how
did that collaboration happen well we
connected a long time ago through Calvin
Harris shout out Calvin
[Music]
when this chemistry one there's
chemistry always so it was just really
nice to be able to reconnect with them
and Vibe I'm really lucky to work with
people that I'm legitimately a fan of
like their voice is nuts their voice is
crazy